hey everybody it's not Monday it's not
Monday it's Friday it's definitely
Friday
it's Monster Hunter Fridays now on
Fridays catch it so we're switching
monster to Monday it's two monster under
Fridays because turns out that's when
the reset happens yeah we get all sorts
of new event quests and cool stuff to do
so why not check out the new stuff
instead yeah unfortunately the
alliteration isn't quite as good which
sucks but yeah we're gonna be doing some
event stuff we're going to check out
what's new probably do some arena stuff
we're gonna do with you guys yeah so you
can you could join in I'm pretty join in
we got the session ID right here right
there for all of you to click and join
in
we're on ps4 this will actually be kind
of exciting because the the actual
quests that are in the event quests are
they're not all like high rank so if
you're still kind of behind a little bit
that's a thing that you can kind of jump
in on right and we can have more people
hanging out which also means I'm gonna
get to mess around with more of my
weapons so I'm excited for that yeah
also apparently we can finally get our
five million celebration pack which I
totally forgot to do so I'm gonna go and
grab that right now because
oh it gets crazy with the armor spheres
how are you all doing on this lovely
Friday getting ready to head off into
the weekend
oh shoot the limited bounties are
another four hours you know that just
means we got a stream for four hours
silly reset right it's gonna be a long
day huh you ready to hunt a lagana for
like four times yeah dude sure I'm in
actually I kind of want the armor set
the
the beta armor set for the females
pretty cool the leggy on it just looks
good oh it actually just gave me the
item pack here I didn't have to go grab
it you got it
dang well I'm into that I'm gonna double
check to make sure that apologies we can
still see the chat just it's a little
smaller than usual we're kicking it
old-school oh man
perfect you guys better I can see it I
can see names I can see messages they
have the flu I feel terrible for you I'm
so sorry it's a perfect time to stay
home and hunt monsters if you can get
yourself out of bed exactly who's not a
fun time okay oh by the way yo I have
some new goals here mm for for certain
weapons oh it's not a thing you have to
claim yeah we can we can do some hot oh
yeah do your thing
yeah man check it out ready BAM now
something screen perfect so we do that
hopefully actually I can't it's weird
what happened to Monster Hunter Mondays
they turned on at Fridays they evolved
so you get to wrap out your week with so
I want to get I got these New York on
tape things but I can get these
decimates so those are the ones I was
telling you about that it didn't want to
like spoil for you that's I want that
I'm really glad that I didn't ruin them
for you and you got to find some newer
ghonte and some boy I can't pronounce
the Z no GEVO does he know Jeeva
yeah there's and Bengal goose oh no
Bengal goose is for the so there's some
Kiran weapons that are pretty
cool-looking that we could maybe farm
because there's a apparently a double
Kiran double cure and events ruff I'm
also really into this those are fire and
ice especially because they actually
looked different from each other which I
remember a while back someone was asked
like oh do they ever actually like
change where you have like different
looking daggers like yeah that would be
cool also these look rad yet the really
cool the Zeno Jeeva stuff just looks
really good so we got lots of stuff to
do I don't know lots of things to farm
in to find whatever yeah
how do you get a job with GameSpot you
work hard persevere do work practice up
and be a good person I like that you
were also in the foursome I wanted to
like transition I was like I want to
wanna get to the point where I could
actually do it man Drake says it's my
favorite guys on YouTube to watch play
monster on earth that is that's very
flattering yet especially when there are
you've got like gaijin hunter and all of
them guys you know it's great you should
definitely yeah watch his stuff I'm very
very flattered that you you feel that
way alright let's see here what do we
want
q don't know if horns drop in low rank
ah that's a good point I think oh yeah
the only high rank fight out of the new
event quests I believe is the one with
like the great jag wrists and the da
Gama and all that so that's okay cuz if
I want to get the the end or the high
rank Kirin weapon I still need to get
the low rank one first so yeah me
fighting a low rank here in will still
get me closer to that which is this true
so I'm okay so high rank here in really
there is this totally I swear there is
yeah it's a knob I haven't bought it yet
but I know Ray's here
lightning strikes twice that that that
high ranked human fight so to me people
in here yet no we don't have anyone yeah
it's okay let's do something while we
while we would get some people in here
what
do you want to jump on the event
question gonna wait on the event oh we
can do some arena stuff it was telling
me so what do you know anything about
you I know nothing about the arena so
basically you don't need to prepare food
before you go in you don't need to like
change it because it gives you set load
outs so you have to like fight out of
your element with sets that they give my
man and try to race through fighting
stuff it's kind of kind of cool like
well that's cool so we can really work
through some of those while people are
there's some easy ones how do you
Superman
dive I assume you mean like the the like
running jump you can do that has a whole
bunch of iframes it's when you're
fighting a monster and you're going to
like a sprint and then you press X 2 to
roll but instead you'll do a dive I
think the ideas wrong might need to fix
it oh oh here I'll put it up and then
like yeah you I didn't I can uh I can
fix it I apologize gone I got it right I
thought we got it right - all right so
you can you can get it off of here if
you can read it and then we'll update it
while you can see it like actually see
that screens very far away
we apologize guys we'll okay yeah so
there's there's the ID what do I have
wrong
M ar e XP w oh I forgot oh you just
switched some of the letters right no
you see it's there oh the way this
program works it kind of like cut it off
gotcha
I actually typed it and write the
program good old xsplit so there we go
that's correct on that one cue there we
go it's been fixed there we go
everyone should be able to join me okay
[Music]
I'm down let's do the first one I know
it'll probably really easy but I just
kind of wanna get my it's all good it's
it's actually kind of interesting this
to go weird like controlled requests one
I also like very you'd be surprised it's
because it kind of forces you to there
we go now we're getting people look at
this is perfect I love it so right now
I'm about hunter rank 46 and I'm about a
hundred and forty hours into the game so
probably a probably a way out way off or
do I use the gun you know what I'm gonna
use the gun cuz I I know the last couple
of shows have been like guns are cool we
should do it also the the patch that
came out they changed gun damage so why
not I'm gonna go want to keep it
together you know
[Music]
if there's ever been a weapon that you
wanted to try this is which I don't know
how to use it but I'll try it
do it uh the best thing uh just mash out
circle a bunch and then press right
trigger and it's the best thing it's
it's what hooked me on it hmm
see I'm at the crucial stage in life we
have to decide do you want to pursue
further your education and love gaming
but not sure what are the industry want
to join do you suggest something so
that's interesting site
I started off like I want to make game
Oh Sam and then I learned that I can't
math my way out of a paper bag so I
couldn't code yeah I dabble a lot with
um like 3d modeling see that was the the
other odd I went I'm like maybe I can
model or animate or something because I
really like I don't know you're doing
you're doing it I believe in you what
kind of ammo is do I have here so spread
shot piercing ammo
[Music]
get fat but it requires a lot of
dedication for me I think my my love of
video editing I ended a bondage
covering games and making videos about
it it's like it's gonna kind of depend
where your passion putting into work
definitely like the best advice I would
give is don't try and stretch yourself
too thin with multiple multiple things
like trying to pick one thing yeah I
completely agree we're working on it
where I met I met URI from Capcom the
other day and I was like dude where are
these man nan Bob wants to watch these
really cool dual guns when are we gonna
get it going no answer yet though we're
working on okay so published switch axe
now I want to switch to the sword
so sword does more damage so it's the
thing you
use the most but uses up by doing a
thing yeah there you go there you go see
you're okay actual you're already doing
okay sweet awesome
I like this weapon it's really good if
you want a weapon that's like half
complex but not like a super yeah if you
want to look like you know which is why
I think okay so it looks like I'm
it seems like it's got like a charge of
either your building up
kind of similar to yes so right now
you're there and you're like no
executives problems can say awaken mode
so your your elements like actives so
whenever you hit something it's gonna
like right ee w so and also if you press
triangle and circle at the same time to
do like a mini mount thats that's a good
time
so it's been a while since I actually
kinda like bought myself into feeling
like gotten stuff so I'm getting back
back into the flow of it so I apologize
[Music]
the best I can can you ride on the
dinosaurs you can jump on them and hit
them abundance which is kinda cool but
you can't like I can't like riding
around in control think you'll ever get
to that point I think you can do it in
the who's like the 3d SP came out a
while ago or something like that
traditional monster on earth like the
box art has the main character like come
over this way someone saying I you
slicing game oh the guns a little broken
it's very good already use up on Miami
for action says just using it I was also
missing with shots
yeah so you get graded how
I'm just kind of like hitting the
monster not actually being where you're
supposed to go he's on the way out those
I also really like to pierce ammo when
you can get like the good line up on
them good yeah I got him come on there
you go
oh boy
trying to wait till you're knocking down
yeah that's that's real good feeling
yeah there we get it
put that thing right down next to his
face and it made the whole thing great
oh also start you can walk around the
camera stops doing that oh I forgot that
that's a thing and I remembered it last
night and I was like ah this is so much
better do you like this game because I
want to shop it shop it my dude it's a
very good game shop that game highly
recommend a shot take taking home I feed
it good good food have a good time drop
an art about it
draw fine art beauty coins Oh God so you
get coins apparently coins and you can
get specific weapon yeah they're the
workshop weapon tree and right now I'm
trying to build the long sword fort
because it's got like every stat that
I've always ever wanted a workshop
weapon tree yeah that's like the so I
had I think I have one
I don't resonate coins for those here
all along receive an invitation
Oh somes got an SOS going I think I
think you think you bought my there it
is yeah it was nice at a our head
censored or a lot of way adapter for it
it's a little out wack right now can all
these cool people in here I love it
awesome I'm gonna check out this SOS see
what oh yeah I'll join in on that yeah
welcome so in spite uh the end boy oh I
think this is what it is are we are we
gonna want to get in there
this is hold on I think I'm finding her
is it I'm searching for that SOS is it
hold on how do I find in our session SOS
you go to join the quest okay so
actually I got a ton or is it is it our
available quests cuz I think so there's
available questionnaires SOS SOS I'm
actually getting a ton more I guess
think that's outside of outside maybe
let's do available helps help our pal
let's help a boy out here fight fight
that lad I feel like we're good to fight
the last boss at this point yeah we're
gonna fight this is this guy this is the
last thing you fight in the store uh and
we should have room for one more if
anyone wants to hop in and and fight
this guy get on in here and then we'll
probably do some event stuff
yeah I think it'll it would be a good
time to jump in on the events is this
game hard it's it's definitely difficult
and challenging but I wouldn't say it's
like you're knock I don't want it it's
not like a Dark Souls kind of thing now
if you're trying to you're not gonna
trick me into saying it it's it's a
monster hundred thing so I was asking
about you have to be online no you do
not play this game completely offline if
you so wish oh we got another person
black star I like it I'm popping in for
the PC version I mean if you have if you
have friends that are playing it now or
you could convince vent friends to play
now I'd say jump in on it the PC
versions always well I imagine the PC
version will be pretty pot well like the
popularity of this game right now leads
me to believe that the PC version will
also probably be pretty popular because
there seems to be a lot of people
waiting for it yeah so it's certainly
you will not be completely missing out
on like the zeitgeist or anything but
you're you are missing out on it right
now
so your call and this is this is a good
version of the game it's not like this
version is inadequate by your games yeah
where we go alright just beat this guy
like a day or two ago
was that yesterday yeah I think so
morning I did it
is it right before a morning meeting
yeah I filled it with a good ten seconds
to spare so I've been like farming this
thing quite a bit it's this boy's farm
status and watch and they say that under
streaming it's maybe the first time I
ever like
yes
[Music]
but also the armor that I'm wearing is
the female version of it is much more
ready so the only thing though is that
[Music]
yeah
Oh does it shoot that means does that
mean that I won I get to keep my eye
patch you got to keep the eye patch with
that son I'm never getting rid of this
eye patch that's just facts
[Music]
back
[Music]
don't worry we got new stuff in the
works that we're going to be into place
any weapons
this matter of a lot of you gotta run
its course
time to try English will still be a
bunch of rad content will do all sorts
of destruction stuff Kanaya for check
out those those discussion videos we've
been doing
good time with them and I'm not just
saying that because I'm in the monster
world
leg Yanis probably the closest thing go
get ya he shoots like ice
oh I didn't know you could do a falling
boulders dang I should I was trying to
do like a jump off the pillar and I
missed I would jump but that I hit
I should pay more attention dude by the
way when you you know my cool yeah Dom
it's fine we here on this guy it's like
the coolest [ __ ] because it's really
long
I actually just saw like a gift this
morning
right it I was gonna link it to you and
I said oh you probably already done this
I I managed to do it during my fight oh
I uh saved on my playstation
shared I'm gonna pull it up I was
fighting a rapper though and a raccoon
showed up and I did a spin blade on the
rap alone and then I went occupation and
I went into the RAF again and did it
again so I liked it it twice
that's you get that on the internet stat
but people need to see that that was
really cool
I think the second one wasn't a thing
it's so rad yeah yeah awesome
what chiller your favorite weapon I go
back and forth between yami-yugi Ike's
longsword and switch axe those are two
might might you go to so I played long
story since since I kind of like got
into the series and switch actions more
of a recent development
yes I would love to farm
it's a fun fight soon
yeah
all the calves are raggy the guy who was
doing this fight already has the looks
like most of the armor set that up
I feel like this was this is a farming
on
he hasn't gone into like his secondary
oh there it is just as I had to talk
about it and there it is boy
[Music]
has a lot of those like AoE attacks yeah
oh maybe I can get it oh he moved what
that was weird
she's just like
oh here it is here this here it is
I caught the tail under room
[Music]
yeah this is this is pretty quick I
think it's the first time I've actually
done this way oh he's already going to
the dang it
somebody warned about yeah that was
really quick
is this a true story yes
I've done this this is I this is how I
start my day off every day to get out of
my house I have to play this you know
diva in the flesh san Francisco's
littered with oh yeah it's a real
problem they've been trying to cut down
on all of the call come on was nowhere
near
[Music]
so if you can hit them enough on his
chest during that that time it actually
like it makes it so all of his life kind
of ways it doesn't anymore right I
always always try to get him and also I
think it doesn't
this is the perfect time to do it too
[Music]
yep
I can't wait till the DLC for this
starts rolling monsters that's I'm at
that point where I just want more stuff
all right we're still
we're doing really really well actually
definitely one see looking out a won't
we will do that bring about gotcha
I think I saw a lot yes
I think it's Oliviana in an herb garden
oh I got it oh snap one moment I looked
away from
it's not always happiness no I got some
bacon
nice
who we got you
yeah
give you a surprise cats
this monster does look really awesome I
guess so yeah
oh hey yeah no but yes it's fixed but
I'm not gonna take that Mike Sarah is an
amazing so you can call out the kid call
out I need a set line the same
[Music]
looking good yeah the I guess this I
guess this official is the Friday show
now oh my god he looks so much more
shiny on your screen it's all that those
those pro pro upgrades this whole area
just looks hey I hate how much I need a
Playstation
and master honors the kingdom that we
wanted yes yeah perfect there it is
there it is there it is with the hallway
to the tail that I should have switched
over to - but you should like oh my gosh
just move it over yeah shoot I should
probably play dual blades more hey I can
try to do again yeah just to switch it
to you for the hold some [ __ ]
classic second switch over to my thing I
all right go back to Ben
you're never seen again this is the last
time you'll ever see my screen how about
I'll mess this up for for Agee I feel
terrible
let's go crazy yo it was reserved that
overconfidence after the first bathroom
adult I'm like I'm gonna do a cool thing
watch this
[Music]
[Music]
I don't even know that notice that we
had all throughout again oh and I just
did it again but you know what it's fine
it's okay not gonna show take my word
when you drop them
this fight is
it's not her it's probably is just
because it's
Wow this is worm hiding
[Music]
so I'm catching myself like half saying
sentences yeah oh thank you I promise if
I sound like an idiot that's because I'm
actually
[Music]
still trying to get that tail
bring down nice
I do like how easy it is
Oh
Oh Oh Joe is this
just get out of there
it's really hurting
and pretty much restricted to like
favorites
the better that's time to get the tail
if it does that move on up oh my gosh no
I was so close
yeah exactly
oh god he's gonna fall into the ground I
need to get out of here get out
[Music]
another part broken but it's still not
the tail
for Friday's you know at this point I'm
still pushing for calling monster
hundred Monday's must up under Monday's
no matter what data which might be
confusing
like I like that is a good alternative
such as we almost got him yeah he's
stressing more about not getting his
tail that's all it's a whole bunch more
cars
no no
[Music]
let me just let me hit you
come on
[Music]
so what event quests do you think we
need head up first the two hearings
there's all the squishy sound on the
boys which i think is the high ranked
one and then there's also one with it
Diablo's there we go
Oh
good God
fireworks going off everywhere
[Music]
[Music]
free-range monster of Friday's I like
that
we could do that if the vaad goes up on
Monday but think about the the silly
irony in this
[Music]
I'm just going 300 Monday's now with one
Friday
I'm yes with bonus Friday I'm gonna be
thinking about it like all dates and
literally everything what are we gonna
call this thing you did it again didn't
you
yeah no it's really satisfying it's
gonna be ended with the tail cut off
really cool it's up to Sam angry
so I believe when you do the tempered
stuff like unlock when you when you get
to the point where tempered monsters are
available you actually
but but other than that like just
killing any monster levels up your rank
yeah we got it
no tail no tail car but you know what
can you do just grab our stuff right
yeah that totally works
Yeah right monster honor mashup that's
good sooo this monster brings a big
fight yeah it does
[Music]
my kids a little low when a game plays a
little high everything there we are
coming in hot but not the right kind of
hot ooh this sounds right I can hear
myself okay I like that fixes it I'm
ready to hunt some mom tailpiece though
oh did you nice so that worked out it's
always a good day when you get to know
what I need to I probably just need a
lot of stuff honestly thanks boy I've
gotten to the point where like I I've
hunted this guy so much that I just sell
his parts to like get money whenever I'm
low instead of like the things you're
supposed to sell that's a lot yeah a lot
yeah yeah grab it all Oh
elder dragon blood I do need that
actually good thing I used that voucher
my palette goes up yeah I'm hunter 8:46
it I got a pretty good pretty good chunk
of my hunter rank from that so that's
it's a good time oh I'm a slinger sniper
but you're a shiny collector all that
glitters is gold only shooting stars
break the mold Smash Mouth
monster Friday's smash monster monsters
monster smash Mondays no frantic frantic
hunting Friday Friday Friday night hunts
front Friday nights all right for
fighting Oh a little bit that hogging a
frog so good that's very good oh I so
stoked about everything
Korea posted a quest we're gonna go
check out some events yeah we got a jump
on that event stuff that's what we're
here for
it is that weekly reset that's the whole
reason we're having trouble coming up
with a new name how do monsters make you
feel
they don't I don't feel anymore did you
just like do a half dab when you sneezed
yeah I actually like typically do that
now that's fantastic
my girlfriend hates it oh I love it
don't ever change please it's just like
I caught out of the corner of my eye
honest you go huh
quit while I'm ahead
it's too late for me unfortunately
hunting monsters is one of those things
that just gets easier the more you do it
oh you know what's really rad yeah I
want to talk about it even though like
no one gets to see it we started doing
it like an office play through a metal
gear solid oh yeah
it was a lot of fun that was a lot of
fun we're starting with the the Twin
Snakes version of one because John Luke
hasn't seen the the crazy cutscenes in
it yet and it's very fun watching his
reaction to that would be the highlight
so far what was your favorite moment
they changed oh definitely the part
where snake flipped in the air when the
gray fox kicked a boulder at him he cut
a part of the ceiling out and just like
bicycle bicycle kicked it at him yeah
that was pretty good
oh I love it also you notice when when I
was talking about you dabbing I didn't I
didn't do a damn so I wouldn't have to
text my roommates so I didn't want to
fall into that see I like this game a
lot more I actually knew what I was
doing my first Monster Hunter game gravy
stick with it I know it's confusing and
it's kind of difficult at first there
are a lot of good resources online if
you want to get you learn on but I okay
I hope you stick with it you have a good
time man these are these all look pretty
tough let's try you want to you want to
just go down the list you want to go
yeah we're gonna start with the the
wicked wild spire wayfarer which show
you guys is this one here we're gonna be
fighting a Diablos and to Barrow to bear
offs still low rank though so shouldn't
be too much of a challenge
it is in the arena though love you to
Zumba thought we're gonna we're gonna
open this one up to the group I like it
that's not what I want to do what went
too far all right we're gonna to turn
back to you now history of metal gear in
the works I don't know I'm not I'm not
to keep her that I can't say anything
odd now she'll Luke the keeper of
everything that has to do with the
history of says no now that's look to be
timely with that I would have to have it
ready for Metal Gear survive oh that's
that's not coming up I can I can do it's
putting real hot maybe one day not not
anytime soon also I feel like yeah you
got to do like the history of Metal Gear
I'm like a like a Metal Gear game that
everyone's looking forward to well
that's I think I maybe miss the boat on
that one
yeah maybe that's okay all right I'm I'm
ready to go okay let's do it yeah that
eyepatch though ass eyepatch is so good
oh it was all just pure speculation it
was all just a clever ruse to throw
everyone off I still want to do my my
drunk history you know what what if what
if you handled all of the regular
history of okay and then I did a like a
like a dark side spin off that's drunk
history of looking like the drunk
history show idea yeah we we just take
that show from Comedy Central yeah we
take that but we wouldn't have any of
the copyright problems we'd call it
something else like we're not good at
names on this show so I'm just gonna
skip that part of this conversation
but basically I want to get completely
wasted while I'm at work and try to
explain the entirety of the Metal Gear
story have have someone who loves King
of Hearts get completely wasted and try
to explain what the hell's going on
inside of Kingdom Hearts oh that was
pretty good Jones you caught the part
this is Woody from Toy Story is good
because there anyone in the office who
is I'm super passionate about I'm sure
our Keenum arts I'm sure there's there's
gotta be there's gotta be someone I
could be completely out basis but I feel
like two more yeah maybe you would our
kingdom hearts go to at least I feel
like you'd be a great person to
drunkenly explain to me the plot of
Kingdom Hearts oh I would listen to some
more trying to explain that I would too
yeah I want that that's what I want I
want to do I want to do I want to do
dump I just want to dumb stuff I love of
dumb things
alright probably doing a little bit of
overkill here but you know oh hello
there so it's good to be prepared that
boy is just oh he's right up where your
eyes yeah whoop okay how do we want to
handle this handle the weak ones first
don't oh we should drop the rocks on
someone yeah I was thinking that oh the
diablos has found us where's the other
the bear up I don't know where the other
one is maybe he comes out Leo maybe he
maybe they couldn't know I feel like the
bear off we could actually get pretty
quick yeah I think so there's a low tier
one these are all wrote low rankings
yeah what am i why am I worried this is
in the bag you just jump in okay again
I'm gonna loot we're just breaking all
the parts
he's already having to keep an eye on
where that oh yeah I was literally about
to ask where's the jobless of course
he's burying so warrior what yes sure if
we could get them or like right in the
middle oh my god drop the rocks on him
John bragging a drone oh I grab this oh
I wish I'd recorded you you watch that
happen where I'm I dragon Aidid a dude
like right in the head it was so good
see here just pick up all these
materials that are driving definitely oh
cool tear out this down wow guys this is
unexpected
I'm wondering where the other barrel
yeah me too I guess we just jump on this
see ah blows now yeah out that's a
really good call for that because a lot
of people might not know that you need
to hit someone to actually get them oh
that is being stung yeah I like it
hello how are you today GameSpot doing
well time to game let's go I like your
name a lot it's good to see you
I hope your day is going well as well
Paul Ryan's gonna rant for chat good
good old times Ryan
Ryan's hanging out doing his thing oh
god I I thought so many of these
monsters by myself but I just expect
that whenever like job Louis goes
underground he's just gonna come and hit
me again hit you
right fortunately that's not the case
okay I'm gonna try and we should get him
to like the middle here yeah we should
we I mean I feel like we're giving him a
little bit of a benefit fighting him up
here oh there's the other bear off he
showed up yeah the I just caught the
door opening in the background come on
down
come on come on down come on down try
dude alright okay that bear off yep
dude get get to the thing he's falling
you oh he is here all in the middle you
run in the middle yeah
I'm gonna stand by this lever gory oh
you're not following me anymore come
over here you big dummy
OOP oh jeez hello oh I'll do perfect I'm
doing it I'm pulling it I'm pulling it
BAM
nailed it perfect let's break them all
the parts off of him now look at the
it's just a spamming like kill feed of
parts being broken that was rad I like
all this is go these are Rena quests are
kind of nice stuff yeah I fell over
tails gone I totally didn't I didn't
carve the last bear off we got the
dragon eater in the movies go away I
mean I think you should have time right
I think so the clothes the flashy outfit
Thank You Herman I spent a good amount
of time farming it and I like that
corpse disappear that in carve a either
you know what where we're going we don't
need carves only carnage yeah it's the
low rank so stop the worst I got to
remember that for the next one though
yeah because the next one was a high
ranked one got just turf war with
everyone get him this tail while they
say match heads and then the dragon
eater should actually be up soon too so
I'm gonna sit here did it give us the
minute warning yeah don't come over here
not yet nope Diablos has gone oh nice
you might not have time I mean that that
a bear out that's gonna go bring him
here do it do it
yeah that's how you do it best way to
end that that's height that's how you do
a monster hunt still gonna dream on
Mondays I dream all day every day every
single day no probably not we're
probably switching into Friday's now
just to kind of keep up again with with
the updates that are happening and do
the event quests like this that kind of
thing yeah that's good I'm really happy
that that work ducks I'm like yeah that
was a good flashy waiting for that that
van that post game screamed to pop up -
all right so onto the next one we're are
we gonna do high ranked one we're gonna
save the Cure in one for for third
well Kieran the Kieran one is a low rank
yeah yeah I don't think it maybe saved
the Kieran one for third okay I'll be a
little tough the high rank one I think
will be fun it'll be fun
there's no like every weak point or
every point on them is a weak point so
you just kind of like tear them up yeah
okay ready
I'm feeling it stoked talking me all
them bits kind of whole bunch of armor
armor cores which is good
calico stuff went up with your hunter
rank 4629 your I think you're at the the
like soft cap before they like let you
out into everything as soon as you
finish the first tempered fight it'll
it'll it'll unlock yet it unlocks once
after you beat the story and then it'll
locks again once you do a tempered which
haven't done yet yeah yeah I tried it
just didn't go well I tried doing that
uh that double B also whatever bagel
goose I think boys I ended up joining a
quest like as it was starting off in
this dude with a heavy bow gun just
carried everything oh okay that's pretty
rad a little poop come here Oh Keith
it's good to see ya
I got some stuff to take care of
real quick yeah I so stoked
I love seeing seeing little Keith get
get turn he's a good a good pig I didn't
even have to use any of my items in fact
I I'm pretty sure I didn't like he'll
once with any of the stuff that they
gave me either that's a thing
what's my favorite spelling I the best
spelling Wilfred everything I find my PV
so I can oh I've been petting him enough
so I've been able to get those outfits
dude you named your your Pookie at all I
did I named him frisk and I gave him the
same color scheme as frisk from
undertale it's a good call
I like it all right I'm gonna I'm not
gonna post it up because if I do it too
quick we might we might fill it before
you get a chance to get it on my quest
okay I've got a couple got some cool
cool guild cards yeah
getting some guilt cards I also have so
maybe I'll accept mine too got some a
squad invite squad stuff receive I'm
gonna I'm gonna take all of these check
all confirm got some new squad members
Monster Hunter Monday still called
Monster Hunter Mondays
I'm gonna send mine to every we don't
think I got actually changed the name of
the squad so it's monster hunting
Mondays in our heart exactly even though
it's on fire it's a this is the the
burden that we carry to forever remind
us of when we were foolish and thought
we could do a showing on Monday I like
it though you prepped that next one I'm
only worried that people might join
before well guess I'm just doing some
tail right here
Safari stuff grabbing all the stuff
doing all the things and we're gonna do
noise
tail rattie's the triple threat one the
high ranked Jukes adventures that sounds
possible Duke suit dukes a good cat I've
heard a lot about Duke yeah let's we'll
save the Cure in one for later
you know I'm gonna do this because I
want to farm that boy do it this hunting
club down to the journal I could like
set a passcode no cuz people can see me
I'm not gonna do that now we don't want
to do that this is open for everyone yes
just give me a sec so I can get in to
the gathering hub away yeah so I wonder
uh I wonder what kind of like rewards we
get from this I don't think they're
adding like armor in yet no not yet cuz
I'm waiting for all the silly stuff to
come in also I kind of want to unlock
like that that Eloy bow an outfit yeah I
think it's supposed to be sometime this
month but they haven't actually given a
time yet yeah
oh cool alright I am putting it up join
a quest there we go vent class triple
threat throwdown yep that's the one I'm
gonna use about your on this one do it
oh we're fighting gear oh it's cool cuz
um I need a actually I would like to get
that guy's armor because it's pretty
cool I also need to find a dota gamma so
that works out pretty well too
actually I need to as well because I
need for my other armor I want to get I
need to level up my bug stick with it um
I just got to I realize I've been
running this whole time about any mega
potions I need to correct that oh snap
that's a that's a pretty serious thing
yeah Oh so since now we're doing the
show on Fridays I can ask people cool
things like what are you doing for the
weekend
yeah got any cool stuff lined up going
to see any cool cool shows cool people
hang out with your pals are you just
gonna stay inside at home and play
monster hunter like me cuz that's
definitely what my plans are that and
digging more into my danganronpa poison
yeah right I like I like how well this
is kind of nice because uh iyx I clean
people in and out yeah it's it's cool
that we were able to get like lower rank
stuff and if people aren't quite where
we are they can kind of do that and uh
there was another person who had put who
had actually set up this exact same
event which is cool so that other people
who aren't able to play with us can
still play with other people in the
session yeah
movies that's a good call Steve I like
it
and any particular movies are just
movies in general kind of like
off-the-cuff c8c and take it as it comes
I don't kind of want to hit go now but
at all should I do it okay it's okay
take your time I'm gonna be playing
Yakuza - heck yeah
that's it's a good time to punch punch
alot of dudes much a lot of dudes it's
actually really fun playing a ps2 game
again it's been a while yeah yeah I
enjoy that I'm excited I really I really
hope we get it over here the qawalli
version same especially because I never
played Yakuza 1 but I play kiwami
so I didn't have that like appreciation
for all the work went into it yeah but
I'm playing 2 on the ps2
if we get Q ah me too I can go back like
already just looking at like a couple of
cutscenes from the Japanese version on
YouTube I was like oh wow
like look how crazy this is you know I
really we get that because that would
actually be a really fun experience
accion I'm hope that's how you say your
name you want capital gamma do I'm down
I'm down I'm down to capture all these
boys if we want to oh yeah I didn't even
I should have set up actually no I have
a shock trap I don't have any I've got
two traps on my person I have a trap I
don't have the whatever you call them
we've got eight tranq bombs so I might
be able to I might be able to help with
the tracking and also with the track I
can help with the trapping it'll be kind
of weird though cuz there'll be three
monsters running around well we'll see
how it goes but yeah I'm I'm down I'm
down to cap some stuff Ajo car he left
the online session oh no all right I
think we're seems like we're ready to go
yeah I'm uh gonna craft my thing really
quick just to be safe craft it's the
thing that I've been kind of getting
used to a bunch I need some sleep herbs
and pear I should start asking those for
cultivating remind me to do that I'm
gonna get back my shut-in so I don't go
outside ever my dude big same he says
tranqs art we're good
heck yeah well I got I got mine too in
case we need backup so do I want to
start with Jaguar probably the quickest
yeah I brought pals
oh and he's right here what up nice
party time I don't know if we need to I
don't think we need to capture the
chacras I'm fine with just doing huh I'm
okay caption the bigger us though yeah
oh 24 get more parts
oh my god there's so many damage numbers
popping up oh I'll sit down to help
booster thanks Kyle
so was asking what this is for it's a
ps4 ps4 Xbox one we're playing ps4 yeah
oh you've been it's done
this poor boy won't even get a chance to
move the way this is going oh my
goodness so that this these are they're
like my favorite things to fight just
because they're like oh never mind
go to sleep you woke me up though oh
you're you're waking me up I'll get
there eventually
yah sir
we go Jairus is down there we go it's
down down oh yeah oh yes all right I'm
gonna farming if I can get the chance
I'm gonna do the same can't see me over
here anyway
Oh someone got another Kyle got knocked
down okay no other guy
I can't do it ah I can't believe this
what was that this guy he's kind of
flailed yeah jerk I don't even see hope
the dogon was up there he doesn't even
know we're here
no this is great this is actually what I
prefer okay did I oh I didn't get to
finish carving I'm watching really
closely on the heartbeat cuz I don't
know if I'm gonna like we're gonna go
too hard right
I would like to capture him if we can
same it's gonna get in here and oh he's
disappearing no don't fade away other
jagira sagres oh he is hurt there it is
alright rank bomb
there we go we got him
yeah yeah took a took a couple of tranq
tranqs what we got right now let's go
for that other boy where's he's walking
around up here somewhere
there he is it's jaylen what up dude
thing sweet I like when the the
creatures are friendly and you can kind
of like hang out with them yeah this guy
is pretty nice she's pretty chill until
I walk in front of him he's a cool boy
so I asked him if there's an armor that
is balanced I'm not sure you mean by
that like like an all-around good armor
um no actually I imagine there has to be
one that has like a decent all-around
balance with elements maybe like you
know it's not gonna be great but you get
a little bit of protection on everything
yeah maybe I don't know that's a good
question
oh I am on fire thanks for the help
I really should custom oh he's already
pretty uh look at heartbeat it's having
a rough time there are no rocks here for
him to eat or dude
look oh no you got I got that blast
blight on me this I was gonna say like
famous last last thing like what what
does this lever do I don't want to pull
it I'm just curious what it does
oh you can hit him with the dragon aider
right now don't wanna we don't want to
but that would actually that would like
literally his head is inside of but yeah
that's real that's real difficult to not
do not do that it was right there uh
Brian Patrick says killed cross armor is
+12 everything so there you go that
seems like to be up so one did activate
it actually this is probably the time to
capture look at the heartbeat that stuff
it's not flat enough it needs to be
flatter more flat
whoo it's getting there it's getting
real flat yeah I'm just so nervous I
don't know if we want to floor and jump
on it yet though oh the girls
disappeared
nobody can okay we captured so we're
good okay just makes me nervous
did I that's how I play this game I'm
nervous all the time
okay now we're good yeah it's dead down
the track Oh
drop those tranqs yeah not only did we
we come here to kill these things we
came he's stuck in a hole we put him in
a hole put us to sleep good good stuff
guys all right nice hon good good time
it sting I'm gonna blow up here in a
second because I still have blast blight
on me oh never mind
we're all good man
all right so next is the double keyring
yes which is going to be oh look at all
those parts an interesting time details
and ooh what do we got here that even
though the Koreans it's not gonna be a
high rank here in am I still gonna get a
elder dragon blood do you know do you
know that there's only one way to find
out because I do need some L the dragon
blood but I don't know if that drops for
low rank I don't know if it does I I
only killed the the ki-rin once meet you
and I never got them I never got any
yeah so it might be it might be a high
rank thing yeah that's I think that's
the only low rank elder dragon it is the
low rank Aaron yeah the game actually
shoot
man I I wish I wish that I had ps4
approaches that it would load faster cuz
like some time he loaded at the same
time though I think I started before you
though not really
yeah ok pet this little boy oh I
actually do have one of the materials I
need or I can make the helmet nice
I'm that's that's the best part of it
that's the best part of the whole set
the helmets pretty cool I can't do
anything with that I'm fine some
bounties here head back up to the
gathering hub alright get my stuff
together
I'm gonna switch out my ecological the
frog was pretty scary to be honest oh
don't don't hurt Keith's feelings Keith
loves his hugging a frog outfit sleeper
band perish room okay as you know showed
up for me want to knock it out or go on
to the the event quest which probably
just do the event quest for now at least
but if you post it up I'm sure people
will join you
absolutely so this is that's that's the
sort of what's up for you as well it's
similar thing it's like zora mag naruse
okay cool I did not know it seems I just
beat him like the other day like I
haven't encountered it much uh-oh
derpy is Akari nice oh nice to meet you
it's got disconnected versus all three
and had to beat oh my goodness oh that
sucks
that's not good at all I was wondering
why you left C perish room and then all
sorts of cool stuff here what were you
trying to try make the tranq bombs
perish room and it was something else
sleeper sleeper yes
yeah perfect and we'll swap fertilizer
for first purchase got that long short I
want you do more morena stuff and make a
fertilizer yeah that's the one I want I
want that sort real bad give me this
sword female hunters are could add armor
slinging this game that's fair I I mean
I'm almost undefeated I've lost once
yeah I mean I've I haven't been able to
beat you at all we should try again yeah
you won't you wanna you want to get back
in and see us but I'm willing a trap nah
dude he's it's all about it's all about
having the heart you know you gotta you
gotta gotta believe as parappa the
rapper would say so I'm gonna go for the
go to my screen that's an interesting
set on you can't really see it too well
because there was the picture set
actually here so I like this one a lot
especially so I like this version
because um this one gives you the most
color options yeah yeah like you can
completely change this and I really dig
that yeah blue looks were really good
but I like the like pointy ears on this
I don't even notice the point of years
yeah yeah but if I did that then the
helmet would permanently be blue yeah so
I think I'm gonna go with this version
that's fair oh yeah I can make the
helmet nice do that they're so stoked
drop it in make a new thing actually I
probably should have quipped that but
let's see so what else do I need here so
the I think the the dude version of that
set has you gotta fight
you gotta get five black Diablos ridges
sounds like we're gonna be fighting the
Diablos kind of name that was doing one
yet oh man I almost
dodo gamma draw
it looks like we gotta fight him again
yeah and Lavos no he's off on all right
well I got one thing okay
finding a tester with a 30-minute time
limit an SOS joined for five minutes
then left with multiplayer health oh my
goodness they should find a way to scale
that back that's kind of kind of
ridiculous of that happens for me the
the worst thing is when someone joins
and they'd like end up getting carted
really quick I feel really bad because
I'm like you I know you didn't mean to
do this but we just failed out of the
quests and I got real sad about it
so can I actually get the next upgrade
for this yeah I can I should I know I'm
not gonna use the the bug bug blade for
this how how far into making this sword
that I want to make am I not very far
not very far at all oh I'm gonna pull
out my my long sword again I think oh I
have all these in my wish list I want to
go there yeah for the for the Cure in
fight that's there's so much better than
than mine yeah yeah the female yeah like
I said this is tied to the so fight I
can keep yeah it still looks pretty cool
but yeah you don't get the cool uh-huh
cape there same with this one that's
almost that's almost worth not having
the eyepatch almost it's pretty rad my
the one I want is this one well that
looks so much better and I can't this is
the oh the beta version and I love it
that's that's to it yeah these are rad I
want this real bad
yes I'm late oh this is cool as well
like look at that that's pretty similar
to the the one for me yeah actually you
know what I really really like I think
how do you get an energy ghonte gem or a
wyvern Jim Tony tea near you can take
Jim's are rare drops off of that guy so
you just got to fight him a whole bunch
or the Weaver and Jim come from like a
set of monsters
I usually firm the the bear off for mine
capture them for a better chance of
getting it so this one here is pretty
cool I like it beta version the helmet
like whoa look at that
oh yeah cuz it makes you have like a
like a mask underneath yeah red eyes you
look so cool
dang dude yeah man there's some cool
glass armor sets in this game I like it
alright so I'm gonna head over in a sec
say yeah you're ready to great I hunt
some Kieran yeah because we're gonna
fight two of them at once and it's gonna
be a mess even though they're low rank
let's do it post it up bright eyes black
dragon shoot
that's a Aug oh I just went for the
first one okay
which actually probably is not the best
bet but here we are
alright
Yatta Tony anytime we got Dan in here
hot rod you back alright I like it
yeah I was gonna switch up to my
longsword and do that very very see down
here with the cats sounds like a plan we
were there good bunch all right a key on
is that he pronounced that I think so I
says they dropped out the hub to help a
friend with your ghonte well good luck
with that thanks for joining us yeah
thanks for hanging out as good fight
fighting with you before good time three
days removed can't get Shadow of the
Colossus very sad about that
oh ho good game I think it's about time
that I played it again it's been a long
time
Roberts just telling me they added like
a cool thing you can there's like a
bunch of coins in the world oh really
it's like 72 of them and if you get him
you get it like a really cool thing I'm
not gonna say what any thing is because
it's a little spoilery so I'll spoil
that game for anyone who hasn't played
it but it's worth it though so I don't
know if it's worthy because there's a
lot of coins yeah and it's it's just
kind of a palette swap thing okay like
the palette swap is really rad I don't
know if it's worth that many like 72
coins that's a lot but it is pretty cool
saying well maybe this will be the
perfect time to pick it up and jump back
into it again I didn't want to play it
again especially since I have a pro at
home and oh boy it looks so good it
looks that is up there with like
uncharted 4 in like how is this game
running on a console oh my god yeah
right see I need to crafts get these
going alright let's let's do this I'm
ready to ready to fight do it I really
like how the kuren makes everything just
to have like a thunderstorm yeah that's
that's real nice
how you get a rathalos coin those are
from the arena you got to fight the
rathalos in the arena my headsets doing
the thing where the sounds going in and
out again yeah just give it a good good
wiggle perfect I'm worried it's gonna be
a thing right I have to like constantly
hold it just the right angle for you I I
think I think it's gone now all right I
mean it's like it I don't hear anything
oh that that's the power you're just
just there we go perfect perfect perfect
I can't move you can't you can't can't
move from there at all yeah we'll
definitely get that fixed are you
actually like like leaning up against
the nurse'll no I'm not but my your cord
is on my my lap I'm worried if I move at
all I'll move your cord and that'll mess
it up gotcha
Kieran is considered an elder dragon yes
even though they are definitely a horse
actually yeah I think it's usually up up
higher so if that's what it's worth to
buy um yes this game guess and show the
classes if that's we're referring to
also yes - very big shadows discounted
oh yeah that's right found one just one
there's another one with it nap just the
one perfect time to strike it's probably
for the best
I rather do not fight to Karen at one so
it sounds to catch them without their
pals oh I don't like the fact that I
only hit it for 13 that's not fun
so you remember exactly how they fight
so they do a lot of little [ __ ] and I
remember them having the armor for a
little bit as anything oh I should have
actually think this this beer is good
for for lightning so that's good is the
opposite of what I really this is all
the opposite of what I want oh my god
I think the second Kieran's near but yup
here it is yep
second Karen showed up it's not fighting
us yet that's good it's kind of doing
its own things or just kind of hang out
we'll be all right
where'd you gone no no nope you went up
to the other one oh no no now they're
both yeah that's not good want to target
one so they know which one I'm fighting
I don't maybe they're not jumping in on
the fight yet nope they're both everyone
jumped up oh nice good perfect
I imagine this won't take too long
cuz it's still a low-ranking yeah
yes I'm riding it bright riding the
horse riding that horse riding them away
well no going back on yeah I guess it
does can you cut the table off I I don't
know maybe come on here we go
yeah even blurry I missed my last hit
that's no good aw we're messing it up
yeah we are
I like it hasn't even done a summer
thing yet which I feel like it has to do
it pretty soon yeah yeah definitely
whoa
I'm trying to leave yeah grab all these
cool bits from dr. pathy Oh me it's
limping keep it from leaving OOP
oh this is unfair yeah this this is when
you kind of feel really bad about it oh
good lord
goob says he's gotta run see you next
time do you see them yeah take it easy
have a good weekend no I need to get out
of where I am I can't be here got it
that was a thing that I did it
nice shoulda stuck out at all Wow Karen
material there's a bunch on the ground
so double cured fights off to a good
start
yeah Oh easy feeling pretty good yeah
I'm gonna these events so far have been
too tough but they've been like slowly
ramping up each week yeah I'm very
curious how they're gonna do do you
think they'll get all just really
complicated and hard or do you think
they'll try and keep a good balance
eventually I think they'll get to the
point where they're gonna be some like
really challenging ones yeah did you
pick up the material on the ground there
was some yeah in material right here
cool that looked like it materialized
next to me and that was really
frightening I'm gonna sharpen up my
sword here right in front of it because
of course
shree isn't too hard to solo but I
wasn't I wasn't sure how it would pan
out with two of them I'm glad that they
didn't both at the same time that would
have been the rough thing that's
a--that's a lot of lightning to dodge oh
hi hello welcome to the ground
exactly it's it's a low-rank hearing
which is really great right my late
isn't almost over uh not not not late
Oh it kind of kind of late yeah we're on
the last event crush event quest look
and then we're probably gonna call it
pretty soon after this we might do maybe
one more thing like another arena quest
or something yeah oh you know what
Bob I haven't heard from Bob in a bit
but if Bob's still here let's do a leggy
on for him okay oh yeah that's right
he's never gonna do that still see one
so what we can end on that well end with
a leg yeah no fights so there's at least
one fight left in the show so you can
still kind of hang out but it's good to
see you yo is true six million ships
killing it
oh hell yeah monster hunters gonna take
over the world I'm so stoked I'm really
happy
I know this was kind of a risk for
Capcom and I'm glad I worked out for
them save me kind of having a bad couple
of years I feel like yeah and I'm glad
that the wind that they got is with
monster hunter cries feel like feel like
the series hasn't been as a series that
deserves a win
yeah yeah like it it was really cool I
keep thinking about it when I like the
first time I was just watching maybe I
was like the Royal Rumble or something
and I was like yo they've got like an
actual ad from Oster hunter on like a
primetime TV event oh wow like oh this
is a good thing oh good
oh yeah yeah yeah I'm really curious if
you can actually come off hotel that
seemed this dreadful says it might be
only love's hammer uh now uh Justin hey
walls hammers hammers it up sure we
there couple of hammer fans know when uh
one of my pals has also been doing
hammer for a very long time it's a very
very fun weapon I'm not too big into it
myself
but now I don't like the slow speed of
it all I can see the appeal though I do
it's it's very true that's it's really
rather than they shipped so many copies
of the game and I'm excited to see how
much that'll happen or how many copies
will sell when they finally release on
the PC I imagine a lot yeah because that
people seem really really the PC people
you see people have been wanting like a
really good monster hunter for a long
time and I mean yeah I mean there been
games that have been like trying to fill
that void for them can't can't beat the
original yeah right and they've got like
the MMO that's in Japan or Korea I think
right off their honor online yeah which
they've got really good detection to
tell if you've if you're playing from a
place you're not supposed to play that's
what a lot of member of it I typed a
thing in on my keyboard and because I
was using English keyboard like banned
instantly they're like that's a QWERTY
keyboard get out of here I can't do this
so that was a thing that circle bash
heck yeah
that's all they look true thing monster
hunter world is the number one
downloaded game on the PlayStation Store
at the moment dang that's cool
so digital sales are up physical sales
are up just sales are up
everyone likes Monster Hunter we're all
hunting for monsters together I was
about to say hey we want to capture the
cure and I remembered you you can't
capture cuz I don't think of it as a
dragon what I really really want to see
happen and I know it probably won't is
that they finally decided to localize
double cross on the switch I'd really
like to have a portable monster
understand something tells me that
instead they would just double down on
on like Monster Hunter world two or
something yeah but like on the real like
double cross has got a lot of monsters
in it a lot a lot it does the thing is
it's more a little more of a traditional
well so the cross cables are kind of
actually the kind of more new than this
actually in a weird sense no yeah they
have the the fight styles thing in it
I'm thinking more like complexity oh
yeah yeah it's it's definitely more more
like that more confusing probably just
because of the actual fights out to you
did the armor perfect is there a way to
like get rip that off and you thought
the weight um so fortunately I don't
have to wait because my highest level of
cutting is above what the armor does oh
nice but I'm about to get killed
actually never mind kind of we're good
I'm not doing back nice no there's
there's the murder I didn't even have to
I wasn't even there for it alright so
we're going to do a high-ranked leg jana
and then we we're gonna have to go call
there we'll get out of here
a load of Xbox and Playstation
cross-party for the scheme's so I could
play with my mate dude same eyewash I
wish every games in cross-party same
this point and I'm really upset that
there's really only one one group one
one company that's holding the back you
know the technology is available we did
it by accident someone someone made it
for was it for tonight that turned it on
yeah for tonight turn it on by accident
it's for tonight it's like oh we've got
it we turn it on it's there for the
rocket league you're doing over here you
didn't pick it up oh that's that that's
that money that money material just hope
they cross play PC and ps4 I mean I
doubt it
yeah have you'd be real good though I'm
gonna make myself a set a rave gear
after this but this is just the standard
rave gear that's true but rave gears
rave gear I'm gonna make myself maybe
those blades yes I can have the basic
version and then eventually I can get to
the higher higher to scoot cool I'd like
to have all of the highest like tier of
each weapon that's kind of what I'm
really gonna do the dual blades that way
I can I can properly like okay time to
switch to this one for this monster yeah
so you're in that point where you're
starting to get together sense for for
differences actually I want to get them
sets going yeah that's a little bit more
complicated I feel there's a lot of
armor it's true and the armor is also
much more dependent on I just want to
look cool fashion hunter is a very real
thing
see you put that there put that there
clean that all up i'ma head back up what
weapon do I want to use for leg jana i
want to do i want to mix it up i want to
do something different maybe I'll do the
beau-site I was playing the bow the
other day and I discovered a move that I
didn't realize it had where you can
actually straight up use it to mount
monsters from the ground oh that's cool
so that's a really cool thing Paragon
had cross-play than epic ooh that's
unfortunate I kind of like Paragon for
as much as I like I tried it out it
wasn't something that I went back to all
the time but it was kind of cool I had a
friend who played a good amount of
Paragon dang was was where they busted
up one day I think at this point they've
already they already had moved on
actually I've been asked him about it oh
man well should be like I haven't played
any games ever since they announced the
closing I haven't been able to bring
myself to do it
Oh No yeah well I'll use my bow okay I
want to start this Kieran tree I need it
by dragon bone twin blade blue dragon
wants to know how how to get rare drops
from Monster so either kill them a whole
bunch or you can capture them and it
increases your chances of getting
something that is a little bit more rare
also it's worth noting that low rank and
high rank versions of monsters have
different drops different items can drop
off of breaking different parts so say
for instance you want to get like a
webbing from like a rathalos or
something and you just got a you got a
focus on its wing that kind of deal I
think vouchers do help but if you're
just going in without any extra like
outside buff things just capturing will
increase your chances and kind of
knowing what part of the monster it's
from helps to okay I got the basic here
in yeah next I need is some Plus hide so
gonna do some later stuff for that yeah
yeah if we don't get cross to play the
monster on world communion and ps4 is
huge exactly yeah I'm sure the PC
community would be huge
I'm still just really stoked about the
fact that every time we get to do a
stream for this like people actually
kind of show up and hang out right we
have people in our room okay I'm gonna
check my optional quests and see if I
have anything related to Leon oh I
actually might have an investigation for
it I do I I have a lakeyanna and you do
guaran
I'm down to do that one double let's do
it
we'll end with that sounds like a plan
that's a double a double-header
all right that's Narcy North camp number
12 okay show me the quest so should we
get me I feel I have to back out there
we go yeah yeah get some food see if I
remember how to use the boats I haven't
done it in a while he gets toasty in
this room no I was just thinking that I
know I don't know if anyone knows but it
when you're stuck in a room for a couple
hours as small as this with all this
equipment maybe it's I feel like in a
certain point though it's just blowing
around warm air but huh
pretty weird though when you scan for
SOS signals it only shows a few no
they're a lot playing I think it's just
to manage kind of what shows up exactly
mr. dreadful also the farts there's
there's a you have to accept like a
waiver a medical waiver every time you
come in here I the I was lucky enough to
never have to do a stream with Marian C
Mon oh no and at least a couple times
Mary Broughton C Mon her dog
Marrakesh former GameSpot employee and C
Mon is maybe the fartiest dog yes sure
just ever I didn't believe it until like
the first time I met them the dog
they're like oh don't worry about it if
it starts to smell it's just the dog and
I was like guys it's probably nothing it
was serious real bad
it was real rough he's got problem
[Music]
there's a couple people who've had to do
a stream with Marion Simone in this room
and apparently his
at what point do you have to shed like
the veil of professionalism like like yo
this smells bad right I can't do this I
need to leave as soon as the stream is
over you just run out of the room and
like get as much air as you can
exactly who'd want to go for first oh
let's get the odor Garen first so we can
we can focus on the leg IANA for the end
I like that you know what I'm not even
gonna grab honey out of there this time
although I actually might be right where
the lakeyanna
is I need my other coating what other
coating can I use on this I don't even
remember whatever it's fine we don't
need to know what you can do after you
finish the main story there's a video if
you want to check it out but just try to
try to work in a promo we actually do
have a video that kind of details what
the the end game stuff is after you
finish the story but dragons basically
boils down to temperate dragons and
getting stream stones and bases you can
figure I'm also I just kind of have the
low volume Oh find a mic a little closer
clicking here I found it I found a boy
found I found the boy he found the boy
cool and I also found the other boy oh
come back here
I'm too far away mostly you are very far
yeah I actually don't know if I fought
the odo Garen with the ranged weapon yet
so that's gonna be a thing this seems
got a rough solo for sure oh shoot this
this guy showed it all we should kill
him to just kill everything oh yeah do
we won't try and capture a teaser
I'm down to capture him I'm pretty sure
I have have a trap I don't have any
tracks
I got a few tracks and I've got traps so
we should be good
oh that was a heck of a shot I'm into
that
ah a spiky boy my favorite kind of boy
and put on my close range coating seems
like an okay time
yeah
come on yeah yeah get them one more time
you know one hit out of that's fine
that's okay I can deal with that
no this is a good this is a good theme -
this is a good thing yeah
oh I should shot him out of the air
get that tail I'm okay with all of
everything that's happening we get the
tail off oh yeah maybe yeah we did
oh nice I believe so yes yes we did
and my shots are way off today
yeah
oh but yeah everyone knows the real end
game for Monster Hunter is actually
getting all the best gear that looks the
best and making it all match it's
fashion hunter fashion honor
oh he's he's hurting pretty bad oh we
could do it
comeback not done with you there we go
oh cool I got that tail real quick come
here hit him get him hit that he got it
do it
blam oh and captured super easy totally
went according to plan
sweet okay and like Gianna's all the way
up at that top where the tail go there
it is give me that tail fast travel to
that one Camp Kyle had the same idea in
mind there we go take me there both
players trash those skills it died
didn't it so matters I mean I actually
didn't die wheelie cap I mean you didn't
die it's done isn't it though if you
have any hot tips on how to not be a
trash boat player giarla your boy is
down to listen to them taking me on a
learning adventure david sculpt me into
the perfect bow player though i didn't
do enough
jump jump dashes like I wanted to that's
that's where I want to be
am i running the right way or is it
taking me back to the ODA Garin I am
running the wrong way get out of here
all right we're engaging and I can't do
it cuz I'm in combat hold on I'll be
there in a second
oh man the tip Nader hit me with the the
best tips get good it's the best tip
I'll probably end up just actually
running all the way to them up at this
point
ah shoot there they shouldn't follow me
up here there we go
take me back up here try the high-ranked
lejiana set for bow I haven't so I I
don't normally play bow is I guess what
I should I should throw out it was just
a thing I decided to do because it's
different yeah are they just like all
the way up in the oh they are yeah not
not the full top but kind of part way
they're kind of almost to the top
although they just they hop down a
little bit oh I'm trying to like sort of
anticipate if you might be headed this
way I'm like half watching your screen
at the time
so that's the thing that the Matsumoto
communities usually usually a good good
bunch hey welcome to the fight
thank you
go I realize those bladed I said just
lost my my feed that's not good no HDMI
cable that's the opposite of good all
over the place
yeah is that that sound related to
what's going on go down and do some some
maintenance Oh kick something uh-huh
just you're too excited about fighting
this leg Jana
yeah no you're you're standing still and
I'm just kind of chilling Oh where's it
going okay it's just going up I kind of
upset that David disappeared didn't give
me any good bow tips is it going uppers
it going down that's going down down who
just hop off you ever get this we're
like you're trying to go down and then
it just doesn't let you it keeps trying
to like instead of jump it keeps trying
to like have you climbed down the vines
ooh
nailed it
nah missed yeah I'm gonna do this though
heck yeah that's that's the stuff do it
again oh my foot fell asleep oh oh no
that's this is the worst possible
situation good oh that's not it's not
what I want to do
you know you know Lance you know call
down
there we go
perfect
now we're really close we could try
capturing Oh do we want to retry I'm
down I like it I like this as an idea
I'm gonna put this strap down right here
on top of it can't move quick use them
tranqs there we go
oh no we killed it oh I'm so close oh
well so close it's okay though
can't you can't capture them all there's
only so much space we can house these
monsters sometimes you got to make the
call right hey my friend meals in the
chat
sorry meals we're ending the stream dang
just like that I think this is about
time I got some stuff I got to finish up
today yeah same actually so it's
probably a good call yeah but it's been
a good time like a good time yes
absolutely but a great Monster Hunter
Mondays summer right fantastic
monster hunter Mondays on a Friday on a
Friday thanks for joining us everybody
yeah we're gonna try and keep doing this
every Friday for as long as the lettuce
until they tell us we'll stop doing it
yeah do all the resets play with you
guys have a great weekend everybody and
see ya next time